today on the map will show another NHL
player Sparks outrage from LGBT
activists by refusing to wear their
religious symbolism on his uniform
meanwhile the New York Times publishes a
patently insane op-ed claiming that
ancient Judaism recognized at least four
different genders supposedly also is
Trump about to be arrested handcuffed
and perp walked and if he is how should
we respond Plus leftists in Portland
hold a funeral for public health after
Oregon lifts its mask mandate because
apparently that state still had a mass
mandate and a group of drag queens
discussed the dangers of appropriation
while being apparently totally oblivious
to the irony in our daily cancellation a
guy running for district attorney in San
Francisco says that crime is just a
quote basic life experience and you
shouldn't complain too much about it all
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you know Biden's plans to help
struggling business owners in the wake
of Kobe lockdowns were to prioritize
black latino Native American and
women-owned businesses goes without
saying that if the roles were reversed
if Biden had said his plans were to
prioritize white male-owned businesses
there would be outrage and outrage is a
massive understatement here if you own a
business you can't rely on the
government to bail you out no matter
your race or sex doesn't matter can't
rely on them you need to take matters
into your own hands and Innovation
refunds can help you do just that if
your business has five or more employees
and manage to survive covid you could be
eligible to receive a payroll tax rebate
of up to twenty six thousand dollars per
employee through the employee retention
credit but you got to go to
getrefunds.com to get it Innovation
refunds has already helped clients claim
over three billion dollars in payroll
tax refunds through the ERC and they may
be able to help your business also this
is not a loan there's no payback it is a
refund of your taxes simple as that
there's no upfront charge either they
don't get paid until your business gets
its refund don't let this opportunity
pass you by see if your business
qualifies for ERC assistance in just
eight minutes go to getrefunds.com click
on qualify me and answer a few questions
this payroll tax refund is only
available for a limited amount of time
don't miss out go to getrefunds.com
getrefunds.com
well the NHL continued its woke
Evolution or Devolution over the weekend
yet another team this time the San Jose
Sharks held a so-called Pride night
where the players were expected to Don
rainbow uniforms in a display of fealty
to the national flag of the United
States of gay but one player James
Reimer followed in the footsteps of
Philadelphia Flyers Yvonne uh pavorov
and declined to participate that means
that there are now two professional
hockey players with moral courage and
you know dignity not more than two
apparently but at least there are the
two so that's good at least Reimer said
in a statement quote for all 13 years of
my NHL career I have been a Christian
not just in title but in how I choose to
live my life daily I have a personal
faith in Jesus Christ who died on the
cross for my sins and in response asks
me to love everyone and follow him I
have no hate in my heart for anyone and
I have always strived to treat everyone
that I encounter with respect and
kindness
I've also cited if you remember we
talked about this a couple months ago
when it happened yeah he cited his
Christian faith as well when explaining
why he refused to participate in his
team's Pride night festivities and it is
indeed a very good reason
um
because a faithful Christian cannot
possibly wear or carry that flag you
can't do that while also remaining true
to your faith it's it is a one or the
other sort of situation
when someone when your employer says to
you oh put this Pride flag on it's um it
is a these are mutually exclusive things
you can either stay true to your faith
uh your Christian faith or you can
um you know participate in this sign of
loyalty to this to this other religion
you can't have both
but I will also say that as a Christian
myself I still tend to think that
you know you shouldn't need to give your
Christian faith as a reason
there's nothing wrong with giving your
Christian faith as a reason and it could
also it is also an opportunity to uh to
display your faith and talk about your
faith so that's reason enough I suppose
to issue a statement like that but
really you shouldn't need to give any
reason at all because it's not up to
James Reimer to explain why he doesn't
want to skate around in a gay pride flag
he shouldn't even have to go that far to
explain it he never should have been put
in the position where he had to decline
such an instruction in the first place
he's a hockey player I mean why in the
world should that job involve displaying
pride in the sexual lifestyle choices of
LGBT people
why should those two things go together
why should he wear it why should there
be a pride night in the first place
it's up to them to explain that to him
it's not up to him to explain anything
to them
now be that as it may he deserves credit
for doing the right thing this is the
only way forward really to to absolutely
refuse to go along with any of this woke
virtue signaling to refuse to
participate oppose it at every turn no
matter the backlash
and in reimer's case the backlash is
coming of course from all the expected
sources the media the left are going
after him for this but also from other
figures within the NHL an executive for
the Pittsburgh Penguins Brian Burke for
some reason felt the need to issue his
own statement condemning James Reimer
for uh failing to show his allegiance to
the gay flag even though again uh Reimer
doesn't doesn't play for the team that
Burks is is an executive for but Burke
said quote
I repeat that I am extremely
disappointed I wish players would
understand that the pride sweaters are
about inclusion and welcoming everybody
a player wearing Pride colors or tape
isn't endorsing a set of values or
enlisting in a cause he's saying you're
welcome here and you are in every single
NHL building
yeah Reimer be welcoming and tolerant or
get the hell out
there's no irony or contradiction in
that message at all of course
but Burke claims that by wearing the
pride colors
he wouldn't be endorsing any set of
values or you know participating in any
in any uh cause
well if that's the case then why is it
so critically important that he wear
them at all I mean if there are no
values and there's no cause attached to
this display then what's the point of
the display and why would it matter if
someone didn't participate
if the pride flag doesn't represent any
particular set of values then refusing
to wear the flag also doesn't represent
or display any particular set of values
see people like Burke want to have it
both ways on the one hand they want to
react with righteous indignation at
those who fail to display ref reverence
and deference to the flag then the other
hand they also want to act as though the
flag is entirely neutral
just wear the flag bigot doesn't mean
anything anyway
but it does mean something and they know
it which is why they care so much
as I've argued recently the pride flag
is a symbol that represents the left's
ideological agenda that's what it
represents
and it has always been that it has
always represented that it was literally
designed to represent that
and by forcing the flag on people I mean
literally forcing it on them in some
cases they're forcing ideological
Conformity that's the whole point
and they're doing it all in bad faith
speaking of bad faith as part of the
team's Pride night activities the San
Jose Sharks Twitter account spent the
evening tweeting alleged facts about the
LGBT community now
there was an actual hockey match
happening uh with the San Jose Sharks
but they ignored all the action on the
ice in favor of tweeting things like
this quote worldwide gender diversity is
seen far differently than that in the
western world or as you may know it most
of us are familiar with the male female
and transgender labels but in other
culture is the existence of the third
gender or even fourth and fifth gender
is common the mux gender is a respected
third gender and
zapotec cultures in Mexico that has
existed for centuries gunah are those
who were born as men but who identify as
women and are attracted to men the GUI
are those who were born as men and are
attracted to other men
they also tweeted this familiar claim
we've heard before in some Native
American cultures the umbrella term to
describe a third gender is two spirits
in South Asia it's hydras in Thailand
it's catholis in Ethiopia it's Ash time
in Polynesia it's
and many more and I mispronounced all of
those of course
but it's also all complete nonsense I
mean never mind the fact that this is a
hockey team it's not just a hockey team
tweeting this stuff out they're tweeting
it during the the match I mean there's
something there's an actual hockey game
going on and this is what they're
talking about instead
but it's more bad faith more
disingenuous sophistry from people who
don't know how to argue in any other way
as I've explained as I've explained many
times two-spirit is a designation
invented by gay activists in the 90s
okay it's not some ancient you know uh
traditional thing that existed in Native
American tribes not at all it was
invented by gay activists recently and
the rest that they mention there are at
best examples of men cross-dressing or
in some cases women cross-dressing
but a cross-dressing man is not a third
gender
if men cross-dress in other cultures and
they do no one ever said otherwise
it's not because they believe themselves
to actually be women in fact that's the
whole point the whole point of they're
cross-dressing and so they're dressing
as something they aren't the recognition
that they aren't that thing is part of
the whole point of the display
now whether this is supposed to be some
sort of spiritual practice or it's a
sexual fetish or both you know that can
differ depending on the case that we're
talking about
but everyone understands that the man
dressing as a woman is a man dressing as
a woman not an actual woman
this distinction is obvious
but they're hoping that you're too
stupid to notice it
and yet somehow this wasn't even the
most egregious example of this kind of
argument just over the weekend on the
same day the New York Times published a
column which is written by someone named
Elliot Kukla with this outrageous
headline here's the headline it said
ancient Judaism recognized a range of
genders it's time we did too
now I want you to listen to How Kukla
supports the claim made in the title and
uh there's you know the the article
begins and there's about 57 paragraphs
of uh irrelevant nonsense before we
finally get to the part that is supposed
to be the evidence to support the claim
that got you to click on the article in
the first place and this is what it says
there are four genders Beyond male or
female that appear in the ancient Jewish
holy texts hundreds of times
when a child was born in the ancient
Jewish world it would be it could be
designated as a boy a girl a tun who is
neither clearly male nor female or as in
androgynous who has both male and female
characteristics based on physical
features
there are two more gender designations
that form later in life the ILO knit was
considered female at Birth but develops
in an atypical Direction and the series
is designated male at Birth but later
becomes a eunuch
there is not an exact equivalence
between these ancient categories and
modern gender identities some of these
designations are based on biology some
on a person's role in society but they
show us that people who are more than
binary have always been recognized by my
religion we are not a fad
now
first of all
note how the writer labels male and
female as genders yet again showing how
these sex versus gender distinction has
been discarded by the people who
invented it because it's outlived its
usefulness to them
and as for the rest of this argument
well again they hope you are too stupid
to understand the most basic
distinctions
okay what is described here
these are cases where physical deformity
makes it harder to ascertain the
physical sex of the individual we call
this now intersex
and uh it's it's a genetic condition it
is not its own gender a person who's
born with eight fingers is not a
completely new type of human being he's
not a new species or subspecies he
doesn't call into question the idea that
humans have ten fingers
he's simply the victim of a deformity
deformities existed in the ancient world
and they had words for it different
words than we have now because they
spoke a different language and ancient
people had ways of um dealing with and
understanding these cases
but they didn't think that a person with
deformed genitals belong to an entirely
separate category outside of the male
female binary
that is a mistake that no ancient
culture was stupid enough to make
actually only the most advanced
civilization in human history could be
that dumb
that's the kind of stupidity that that
you could only find in modern Western
culture
in fact if you want to know
exactly how ancient Judaism felt about
so-called gender roles
here's what the book of Deuteronomy had
to say about it quote a woman shall not
wear a man's garment nor shall a man put
on a woman's clothing for anyone who
does such is an Abomination to the Lord
your God
I mean the New York Times brought it up
so that's what it actually says
and also some advice there that we would
do well to heed today
now let's get to our five headlines
okay so the big story over the weekend
of course was that uh president Trump
was supposed to be arrested uh tomorrow
on Tuesday
and this was coming as far as I could
tell primarily from Trump himself who
said that this was the result of leaks
that he that he found out that he was
going to be arrested on Tuesday
um and
then some more information comes out it
seems that uh maybe that Declaration was
premature so it's still not exactly
clear what's going on but I'll read the
latest this is from uh daily wire it's
the headline the article from today a
lawyer who previously advised ex-trump
lawyer uh Michael Cohen's is a lawyer
who advised Trump's lawyer former lawyer
Michael Khan is expected to testify this
week in the Manhattan grand jury
investigation into former president
Donald Trump's alleged 130 000 hush
payment to porn actress Stormy Daniels
during the 2016 election
attorney Robert Costello is reportedly
prepared to attack The credibility of
Cohen who allegedly made the payment to
Daniels on Trump's behalf and was later
improperly reimbursed for the expense
the Associated Press reported that
Costello claims to have information that
contradicts some of Cohen's current
statements and that could be exculpatory
for Trump the report said that the um
Manhattan district attorney Alvin
Bragg's office uh last week subpoenaed
Costello's Law Firm for records and
invited him to provide testimony on
Monday afternoon
and now he is going to provide testimony
this is what Trump said on social media
quote the most important witness to go
before the New York City Grand Jury a
highly respected lawyer who once
represented convicted felon jailbird and
serial fake Storyteller and liar Michael
Cohen will be doing so tomorrow
afternoon this information he will
present will supposedly be conclusive
and irrefutable that's Trump saying that
Trump ignited a firestorm over the
weekend after he claimed on social media
on Saturday that he was going to be
arrested on Tuesday a spokesperson for
Trump later said that Trump has been
given no notification quote unquote that
there will be an arrest next week
um Trump's remarks came after report
from NBC news said federal state and
local law enforcement agencies were
analyzing security assessments and
making plans to prepare for the
possibility that Trump could be indicted
next week but no date was given in the
report
so I guess that's where it starts with
uh mainstream media reports that they're
preparing for the possibility of
protests and uh quote unquote unrest in
New York
if
Trump is indicted but he hasn't been
indicted yet
and then Trump indicated that this was
going to happen on Tuesday and now we
find out that you know there's this big
witness that they're going to hear from
today at some point and Trump says that
you know it should be uh it should the
the testimony should what's the word he
used in irrefutable and conclusive
um
so still not clear exactly what's going
to happen
if the arrest is going to be made or not
but here's what Trump was saying let's
let's back it up a little bit this is
the most recent update
let's go back to this weekend and um
back when the story was that he was
going to be arrested on Tuesday
this is what Trump posted on social
media
he said and we say social media to his
uh his website truth social
it's time he said we are a nation in
steep decline being led into World War
III by a crooked politician who doesn't
even know he's alive
true but who is surrounded by evil and
Sinister people who based on their
actions on defunding the police
destroying our military open borders no
voter ID inflation raising taxes and
much more can only hate our now failing
USA we just can't allow this anymore
they're killing our nation as we sit
back and watch we must save America
protest protest protest
um and then in a separate post he again
called for people to protest and take
our nation back
all right
so here's a few things here
uh whatever happens
this whole thing is a farce and an
absolute disgrace
Alvin Bragg I mean from this D.A in
particular this is one of these Soros
DA's Alan Bragg uh he lets violent
criminals roam the streets
okay right right now there are violent
known violent criminals criminals that
are known to the system because they've
been through the system and they're let
out on parole even though they're known
to be uh dangerous to the to to the
community or they're never put in prison
to begin with
they're giving these slap on the wrist
sentences probation or whatever else and
uh and they're allowed to roam the
streets until they commit a crime so
heinous that even Alvin Bragg has to put
them in prison for at least longer than
like a couple of days
so that's what's happening in New York
just like in so many other cities across
the country
and yet while allowing that to happen
Alvin Bragg is spending all this time
and really it's years and millions of
dollars
trying to nail Trump on some frivolous
ridiculous misdemeanor charge
and maybe they'll try to turn it into a
felony but really it's it's like at at
best what they're going for is a
misdemeanor charge
which is also something that by the way
if
if paying hush money to a mistress if
that warrants all of this the grand
juries and everything else then there
should be grand juries convening for
like 90
of the politicians in Washington DC it
doesn't make it right like you shouldn't
be having Affairs in the first place
um you shouldn't put yourself in a
position where you have to pay hush
money
but everybody understands that this kind
of thing goes on
all the time very frequent
and if they're not paying much money to
a mistress it's to someone and whatever
ndas I mean all this kind of stuff is
very very common
and yet in Trump's case they want to
pretend like it's some sort of uh
unprecedented infraction
it's so there's a there's a theme that
emerges well it's not just emerging now
it's been present all along but it's
just this same situation with the
classified documents
find out that Trump has some classified
documents in his house and they pretend
that oh this is an unheard of how could
he possibly do this
then we come to final Biden has crossed
classified documents but they all do
this
um so the entire thing again is a farce
it's a disgrace it's um
you know and even to call it a farce
probably understates it
because what they're actually doing here
obviously is they're trying to throw
their political opponents in jail
and they're doing this at a time when uh
and I you know I I have to continue to
harp on this because it's an important
point but you've got conservatives who
are sitting around
debating amongst themselves whether
we're being too mean
okay this this conservatives who are
worried
that the words we're using and that's
all it is they're worried that the words
we are using
about the opposition might be too mean
and rude
and so while we have to spend
weeks at a time
debating the types of words that we use
Democrats are
simply in the process of trying to throw
their political opponents in jail and
not just any political opponent but the
number one guy
the former president and right now the
the you know assumed front-runner for
the GOP nomination you want to put him
in jail
so they're doing that
well we're saying are we being a little
too rude to these people
this is just if this is not a wake-up
call Then I then
I don't think you'll ever be if this
doesn't wake you up then you'll then
you're
then I guess you might as well just stay
asleep
it's incredibly obvious and it's been
incredibly obvious for a long time that
we have to fight fire with fire we
really have no choice
okay so we can
be gentle and we can be nice
and we can uh respect the unwritten
rules and all the norms
we always hear about these Norms from
the Democrats they're violating the
norms
so we can allow ourselves to be
manipulated into respecting all that
stuff and being nice and being gentle
and everything else and
being relatively polite and um
and uh moderate and open to compromise
and all that we can do that
but it's not going to stop the other
side from
ratcheting things up further and further
which is all they ever do
they're not going to look at our
niceness and say well you know these
people really they're not so bad
actually
maybe we should lay off a little bit
you know what maybe throwing Donald
Trump in jails a little bit too far I
mean look how nice they're big
that's not ever going to happen
fire with fire is it's not look this
this is the point
it doesn't even matter at this point if
you're comfortable with it or not
you have no choice there's no choice
they don't leave us any other choice
and in a case like this what does fight
what is a fighting fire with fire
meanwhile means you know potentially
various things but here's one thing it
certainly means
is that the Democrats
who are getting away with their own
crimes
they need to be thrown in prison
so when you've got Democrats trying to
throw president Trump in prison
um the response should be
a a D.A who's actually on our side and
there are some of them out there they
don't run major cities but you need
somebody like that to launch an
investigation into the rampant criminal
activity of a high-profile Democrat and
try to throw them in jail
it's all legal
it's like actually investigate the real
crimes committed by these people and
throw them in jail
that's not going to be us
um taking things to a new level or or
anything like that this has already
happened
and so we can lay down and get
steamrolled or you can fight back those
are the only two options
I mean just think about there's so many
examples of this but but
like January 6th we talk about this all
the time but
perfect illustration
January 6 happens
and the Democrats spend
the the next two years and counting
trying to hunt these people down like
dogs and throw them in prison for years
at a time
meanwhile just months before that you
had BLM and antifa rioters
plaguing cities all across the country
and the Republicans were ready to just
let that go they were ready to move on
from it
and they did they still have
there was never any never any serious
effort to actually track these people
down and throw them in some some people
went to jail for a little bit but uh
nothing like what we saw with January
6th
and even more importantly there was
never any serious investing we talked we
heard talk about investigation but there
was never any serious investigation into
the people who were funding and
organizing the BLM riots
okay when you have these rioters show up
and show up in Vans and everything and
all this coordination people showing up
it's like pallets of bricks but
there's never no one ever looked into
where is this all coming from
how is it so well organized
fire with fire would mean actually
finding the people responsible for that
and throwing them in prison
um
the other question you have to ask is uh
what exactly is the political play here
with Trump
they're going after Trump it's yeah they
would love to put him in jail for 15
years but that's not going to happen on
a charge like this
and he's probably not going to spend the
day in jail
um although from from the reports that
we were hearing on Saturday they at
least wanted to perp walk them I mean
they wanted to put them in handcuffs and
perp walking and they wanted to do that
and let's say they do it
you have to wonder what exactly is the
political play
because I think most people even on the
left understand that if you do that
um it's a horrible thing for the country
But ultimately it will probably help
Donald Trump politically
certainly in the uh in the in the
primary
it's going to help him
as well it should
you know it's it's you are
turning him into a martyr and you're
you're putting handcuffs on them
marching around
um
I don't see how it helps in the general
I think I think like when it comes to
Trump in the general there's nothing
that can help or hurt everything is
baked in and you feel how you feel about
Trump and I I don't think anything's
going to change that
I mean let's say they actually did a
restaurant but throw them in jail get to
a general election
um I don't
I I don't see anyone who hated Trump
saying you know what I feel bad for him
because I'm going to vote for him
and I certainly don't see anyone who uh
likes Trump or at least opposed to the
Democrats saying you know what I want to
vote for the Democrat now because they
put him that's not going to happen so
general election it's not going to move
the needle one way or another I don't
think anything can at this point because
it's all baked in
in the primary I think it does help
Trump
potentially in a big way I mean you
could make the argument that if they
actually do this
and they put them in handcuffs and March
them into a jail cell
that if they do it on Tuesday he wins
the primary on Tuesday
and then and maybe this is where you get
to conspiratorial and uh but but then
you have to wonder is that part of the
reason why they're doing it because they
want him
they they want to run against them they
want him to win the GOP Primary
you know I I tweeted that over the
weekend and uh there were people saying
that that's a it's a crazy conspiracy
theory doesn't make any sense
maybe it is maybe I'm maybe I'm uh
giving them too much credit the
Democrats
in assuming that they can engage in this
kind of strategic thinking
and you could certainly make an argument
and some people made this argument to me
and I do find it persuasive that um even
if it has the effects of essentially
winning the primary Forum which I think
there's a good chance it will
that's not what they're up to they're
they're just motivated by their
just insatiable hatred for Trump and
they're going to do whatever they can to
go after him uh and they're not even
thinking that far ahead
I think there's a lot to be said for
that theory as well
all right
this is a pretty amazing clip from uh
some podcast other than show what
podcast is it doesn't matter this
featuring a group of black drag queens
talking about the dangers of cultural
appropriation yes these people are very
worried about appropriation listen
there's such a long rooted history in
appropriation from Black Culture like
for instance like when I go to the
Metropolitan Museum and I see things
that they've taken from Africa I see
things that they've taken from Nubia and
then you go yes and then you go and you
look at these pillars and then there's
this white man Samuel something
something 1800 going and saying I'm
putting my ownership on something that
was never mine to begin with and then
they go yeah I discovered it so then it
gives me this ownership like I can take
it and it can be mine and I feel like
it's that entitlement that is one thing
that we really need to discuss like
there is a way I feel to very much so
appreciate somebody's culture but so
many times like Bob says there are times
where you know they cite the source but
they don't
hmm
yes these people are worried about
appropriation
this is this is like irony
overload and what the hell is this
those little baby heads on this uh man's
dress there I think that's am I am I do
my eyes deceive me yeah that's that's
what he's wearing
let's not uh satanic at all so you've
got yeah these people it's like I can't
even say dressed as a woman because I've
never known a woman to take the severed
heads of baby dolls and fasten them to
her dress that's not something a woman
would do but they are attempting anyway
to appropriate Womanhood and at the same
time they're a warning about the dangers
of cultural appropriation
and what's what's the example they give
for cultural appropriation the first
thing he says is a museum
so taking artifacts cultural artifacts
and putting them on display in a museum
is appropriation now
isn't that what exactly is the
difference can can these people
articulate any more a distinction
between
um paying homage to a culture or uh you
know paying tribute to a culture
showing respect to a culture and
appropriating it is there even any
difference anymore in their minds of
course there isn't
I mean there was a time not that long
ago like I don't know 15 seconds ago
where uh for cultures for museums to
have Multicultural displays that was the
politically correct thing to do
it also made sense for a museum because
if you want to use it if you're going to
a museum you want to learn about world
history it's going to show you artifacts
of world history
but now you can't even do that without
being accused of appropriation
and yet these men who are
wearing Womanhood as a costume
are somehow not guilty of it themselves
all right here's a interesting story
from the post-millennial it says on
Saturday a far left radical group called
mask block PDX announced via Twitter
that will be hosting a funeral to mourn
the death of Public Health following
news that Oregon would be ending its
mass mandate for healthcare settings on
April 3rd
this is uh what year is this it is 2023.
and they're just getting around to
ending the mask mandate now
but that's uh for normal people that
it's it's way too late in the game it
should not have taken this long but for
these leftist activists it's too early
we're still in the middle of the
pandemic they say the ceremony is
scheduled for Monday March 20th and will
take place at Pioneer Courthouse Square
a busy downtown Portland Gathering Place
those who choose to attend are required
to wear n95 masks are similar
so this is what they're talking about
doing uh today actually it's going to be
a um a memorial service
to mourn the end of Public Health
because Oregon is is lifting a mask
mandate in the year 2023.
you know I saw the story and it made me
think about something I've been thinking
about a lot actually because as we've
been traveling around the country and
we've been to a lot of liberal areas and
you know we've been to
we've been we've been to all of them
basically
um East Coast to West Coast
and
you still see people wearing masks it
always even though I'm ready for it and
I know intellectually that they're out
there The Mask wearers uh it still blows
my mind a little bit each time I see it
someone's still wearing a mask even at
this point
um wearing them outside too so you still
see that even in you know really only in
these liberal bastions
but
not not
that much masking still even in the most
liberal areas in my experience
um the people who mask are in a minority
and of course in most places in the
country the same places anyway
um
there's basically no masking at all
which is very interesting because I I
will admit
this is something that I was wrong about
you know I I thought
if you go back
I don't know two years ago when the mass
mandates were still in place everywhere
nobody was wearing masks
um
I thought I probably predicted publicly
that masking was basically here to stay
even after the mandates were left I knew
eventually they'd lift the mandates
but it seemed to me that people's brains
had been so broken that probably half of
the country maybe a little bit less but
close to half would continue wearing
masks indefinitely
um and there was reason to think that
because for a couple of years at least
most places that you went
it was it was like 100 Mass compliance
yeah the outliers who wouldn't wear it
and you know maybe they get yelled at
maybe they didn't
um
and then you got to a point where and I
know this from experience
you could walk around in most places
including airports and not wear a mask
even though it was mandated and nobody
would say anything to you I know this
because I went into dozens of airports
during the mask mandate uh years and I
didn't wear a mask in the airport now on
the on the plane you couldn't get away
with it they'd force you to wear it but
in the airport anyway you really didn't
need to wear it they wouldn't say
anything
and yet most people wore them
and I assumed again that was because
people's brains had been broken they've
been so conditioned that they were
wearing it because they were terrified
and that's why you saw this near 100
percent uh Mass compliance in most
places
but then they lift the mandates
and also
you know and and it's not just the
mandates but but also the public
pressure goes away and almost all the
masks go away
to the point where now even in the most
liberal areas I go to Seattle or
Portland you'll see masks but they're
still in the minority
and that is uh kind of fascinating to me
I don't
I don't know if it's a good or bad sign
because what that means is that you had
so many people wearing masks all that
time not because their brains were
broken I mean I guess I'm glad their
brains weren't broken
but then it means that
for so many of these people they knew it
was ridiculous
and yet they did it anyway out of sheer
obedience
I'm not sure what is better
what would I prefer to think
what's more encouraging
the thing that people really were just
scared out of their minds and they
thought they had to wear them so that
they didn't get sick
that's what I sort of assumed
reality appears to be
given the fact that as soon as they said
don't worry you have to wear masks
anymore almost everyone took them off
um then it would seem to indicate that
most of the people wearing the masks
knew that it was absurd knew that
there's no reason to do it did it anyway
out of just
pure obedience
and in the end maybe it's because I'm a
pessimist but in the end that to me
seems uh
even more disturbing
in some ways
because what it tells us is that
you know the the powers that be they
don't even need to necessarily brainwash
everyone
people are willing to comply willing to
be obedient
if you just tell them to do it
all right one other quick thing so after
uh this is from uh Breitbart it says
after eight seasons four sex change
surgeries quote unquote and countless
hormone treatments TLC's I am Jazz star
Jazz Jennings still doesn't feel right I
don't feel like me ever Jennings
revealed in a recent episode Jazz
Jennings was born a boy and declared
himself transgender at the age of five
confess feelings of dissatisfaction to
his mother Jeanette I just want to feel
like myself all I want to be is happy
and feel like me I don't feel like me
ever uh Jess at an emotional exchange
caught on camera so this
reality show is still ongoing and Jazz
Jennings has been
um
quote unquote living as a girl
now for years
but isn't happy I think we have the clip
of that let's watch it so um are you
feeling like you wanted to start talking
about
are you okay I'm okay I'm gonna cry
but you know I can't get out of my head
I know no listen
it just doesn't stop
and stops okay I know what you're going
to we've been nervous no it still
doesn't stop now and I'm already going
back to negative but the more you're
talking about yourself it gets harder
you're digging in and you're it's making
you put a magnifying glass on what's
already difficult as it is
so this is hard for you I know and you
don't we don't want to push it I know
I'm the one doing it like I know you're
almost enemy
I feel kind of all over the place and
like my mind is very cluttered and not
clear and I really want to have that
Clarity I really want to understand
myself and be able to read my own soul
and what I want and it's just very
challenging and I think I'm kind of
breaking down a little bit and spiraling
into negativity
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like we've ever
uh okay so that's
actually in a really depressing and
terrible way it's it's a powerful clip
because of the words that he uses I
don't feel like myself ever I don't feel
like myself
now you hear from the abusive this this
mother I mean obviously all these
parents that Force this on the kids are
all evil but this woman in particular
you know it's different for her because
we've seen this has been we've seen this
documented she has documented herself
psychologically abusing and uh
brainwashing and conditioning her son to
believe himself to be a girl we've seen
this over the years
and uh so you can see just how
evil this woman is you know she says
I've been through it I know no you
haven't
really you've been through that
your son is mutilated beyond recognition
and he's gone through with the whole
quote unquote sex change quote unquote
gender affirmation uh medical you know
these the whole catalog he's got
so you you know what that's like do you
lady no you don't you have no idea
no because you were able to go through
childhood and then early adulthood uh as
yourself
okay you didn't have this false identity
imposed on you
so you have no idea what that's like
and you never will know
I don't feel like myself you know that
is uh
that is
as direct as we're gonna hear certainly
as direct as as a TLC reality show will
allow us to hear
of a trans identified person saying this
is a mistake
I mean all of this was about all this
identifying as a girl getting the
surgeries and drugs it was all about uh
supposedly him living as his quote
unquote true self and even after all of
that says I don't feel like myself
because yourself has been robbed from
has been taken from you
and also keep in mind when you look at
that clip
you know we hear this discussion about
um regret after surgery regret after
transition that we hear stories of the D
transitioners
and we know that this is much more
common than what the powers that be will
tell us
but also remember that
the people
the trans identify people who are not in
the who don't who do not officially
count in the regret category or the D
transitioner category many of them
and I would say a vast majority of them
are in this kind of category
where they're not going to come out and
say I regret it it was a mistake but
it's very clear they're still unhappy
that's why suicidality is is you know
highest after transition uh still very
unhappy is still in deep despair
but what they also have
you know they they have an intense
psychological motivation themselves to
not fully admit to themselves that it
was a mistake because there's no turning
back and so if you admit that it was a
mistake then where you go from there
but they also have you know Jazz
Jennings
has his his mom
who's there and won't allow him
to consider the possibility of those may
be a mistake
because of his mistake for him it wasn't
really his mistake it was her mistake
it's not that jazz Jennings didn't make
a mistake because this happened to him
when he was a kid before he could
consent to it this is a mistake
and I say mistake in the sense that it
was the wrong thing to do not like it
was done accidentally but this was a
mistake made by the mother
the mother brainwashed this kid into
doing this and now she's going to keep
that brainwashed going brainwashing
going
so he may never fully come to terms with
what happened to him at least as long as
his disgusting wretch of a mother is
still alive
so something to always keep in mind
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
Joseph says I'm sitting at my kitchen
table with a beer tying a batch of
Adam's flies
the kids are all put to bed and my wife
is sleeping soundly listening to
podcasts and almost interested in
wondering why other men aren't after the
same things out of life
that is uh the simple Joys and in fact I
think um I'm glad to know it's not just
me I think that this for many men the
the time when both wife and children are
in bed these are uh sacred time for a
man for a father I often use that time
to watch boring documentaries that no
one in my family would want to watch
with me use it to do different things
but um
and that also shows that even after you
have kids you have a family you still
have time to yourself you don't
sacrifice all that as people like to
claim Amanda says he ate pudding with
his fingers if that's the worst thing
that they can find he's literally the
most decent and honest politician in
America
well not only that but as I tried to
argue I think you you could argue that
eating pudding with your fingers is a
sign it's a it's a display of
of leadership you know what it is it is
leadership in a time of crisis
where you have the pudding you don't
have the spoon
crisis what do you do how do you how do
you navigate the situation
um do you give up
do you turn back and say oh I don't have
a spoon I guess I can't consume this
pudding
that's what a lesser man may say
but not around to Santos
at least that would be my spin if I was
his uh
if he made the mistake of making me his
spokesman
Thomas says the real culprit in the
pudding Scandal is a snack pack for not
providing a small plastic spoon taped to
the side
and that's something I that's that's
also a very important point if I was
spokesman I think I'd make that point
too we're also deflecting the blame at
the same time
and you're right why doesn't it come
with a small spoon
um
Andrea says I gotta say I've eaten
pudding with my fingers not as a normal
thing but I did it once I like DeSantis
a lot and these Bombshells don't alter
that
yeah I've never done that with pudding
but I have I've been in fact recently
I'll admit that I was in a situation uh
we were traveling I was in the hotel
room and I ordered uh ubereats you know
some um takeout food and I asked you
know you can ask for the utensils when
you order the ticket but they didn't
bring the utensils and I didn't notice
that until I got up to the room and I
looked around the room and you know most
hotel rooms don't don't come with
utensils this one didn't so I didn't
have any utensils and I didn't use my
hands but I ended up just like peeling
off a piece of the of the styrofoam
Carton and kind of using that as a
makeshift spoon
and I could have gone down stairs
because there was a bar there where they
would have given the utensils but I
didn't feel like walking all that way so
I had to
my laziness meant that I had to innovate
we've all been in situations like this
uh
let's see Sauron says Matt and Michael
should have a debate over the existence
of aliens
he doesn't he doesn't want that
he doesn't want none of this smoke as
the kids would say when it comes to the
aliens conversation
uh Laura says I don't judge women who
stay home to raise the kids but I don't
like the idea that domestic labor is
predominantly the wife's responsibility
a healthy marriage is a 50 50 split
well that's completely false and I I the
people that this is so common but I
always have to assume that the people
who say this are not married themselves
um certainly not in that a happy
marriage if you actually think that no
matter how you split up the domestic
labor I don't care but
the 50 50 split thing
is not how a healthy marriage operates
if you think about what you're saying
that's that is a
that's a Business Partnership so anytime
someone says that they say healthy
marriage is 50 50 split I already know
for one thing this is the kind of person
who refers to their spouse as partner oh
my partner and I went out for dinner
last night
where when they're describing their
spouse you you can't even as far as you
know they're talking about an actual
business partner
um
and so yeah 50 50 split in a business
Arrangement makes sense
uh although even there it can cause
problems
but in a marriage is not because what
does 50 50 mean it means that whatever
the task is right you're going to do
exactly 50 of it and then use your way
for your spouse to do the other fifty
percent
this is like this is how my kids operate
it's very it's actually very childish
and certainly self-centered selfish way
to go about it this is what my kids will
do if I tell them if I tell both in fact
just yesterday it said both boys go
upstairs and clean the uh clean the
living room upstairs because you left
your towards a little voice and I heard
them
up there negotiating how much each of
them would clean and so they started
actually accounting the number of things
on the floor as well you clean that and
I'll clean this because nobody wanted to
clean one percent over 50 percent
and so I had to tell them
stop negotiating just get it done I
don't care if one of you does 80 the
other does 20. it just just get it done
that's what I care about
so it's one thing for kids to operate
this way you know obsessed with this
idea that everything has to be equal
everything has to be 50 50. but that is
that is poison to a marriage
what you actually do is you give 100 of
yourself
um and it's not going to be exactly
equal because you you are not equal you
are equal means the same okay when two
things are equal they are the same
and you are not the same as your spouse
you are two different people
and if you're both giving 100 of
yourself
then you're going to end up doing that
in different ways
and if you take one isolated you take
like one isolated part of the marriage
like for example who does the dishes
and you look at that on its own isolated
from everything else then you could say
that well this is unequal because I do
it more often than he does
but if you look at the the entirety of
the marriage
and all the things that are necessary to
keep to keep the wheels moving
as long as both are giving 100 that's
when you see that things if you if you
want if you want to use this phrase
things quote equal out
you know the victim mentality has become
so pervasive that any and all behavior
is excused not only is it not your fault
you're all right just the way you are
the reality is no one has ever gotten
anywhere in life through complacency no
success has ever been achieved through
complacency no meaningful growth has
ever occurred but if you just put forth
some effort it can literally make a
whole world of difference
I'm sorry I use literally they forced me
they put in the that's not the correct
use of the word literally Jordan
Peterson expounds upon this in his new
five-part series vision and Destiny on
daily wire plus here's a clip
you're not all you could be
and there's pain in that and there's the
necessity for a certain amount of
judgment about that and even a certain
amount of exclusion because what you are
that is insufficient in some sense
should be not be allowed to propagate
further but if it's conjoined with
encouragement it's like yeah you're in a
rough situation there kiddo but you know
here's some things about you that are
virtuous and good and they're pretty
powerful actually and if you just
made those more manifest you could
dispense with a lot of this immaturity
and misery and you could expand yourself
out into life physically and
psychologically and
you could start
walking this pathway that makes things
better and the thing is that as soon as
you start walking the pathway that makes
things better then things immediately
become better because your whole
orientation changes and you know if
you're in a bad place but you're
escaping that's pretty positive
even if it's a bad place and you might
think well it's still bad but it's
better it's like well that's a lot
that's a lot better than a bad place
that's getting worse that's for sure
because that's hell hell is a bad place
that's getting worse
well the fifth and final episode of
vision Destiny is out now it is
literally tremendous exclusively for
daily wire Plus members you got to join
now at dailywire.com subscribe to watch
vision and Destiny now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
businessman by the name of uh snehall
and Tony took to Twitter on Friday to
recount the story of a colleague who
went to San Francisco had the full San
Francisco experience we might say and
didn't much enjoy it he tweeted quote a
teammate Visiting San Francisco for an
off site called me frantically last
night after dinner at Fisherman's Wharf
they came back to a smashed car window
and two stolen backpacks ten thousand
dollars in gear loss passport's gone Etc
so a classic San Francisco welcome they
received though Antoni reports that this
was something but something a little bit
more than you know uh than it's a little
bit more sophisticated than your average
Smash and grab by a homeless vagrant he
continues quote laptop bags were in the
trunk nothing visible from the street a
typical description of a smash and grab
yet thieves were able to find a specific
car and knew to pull the rear seat down
and reach into the trunk how I explained
these these aren't homeless randomly
smashing Windows these are professionals
using Bluetooth scanners to find laptop
bags and idle iPad Bose headphones Etc
all emit Bluetooth my teammate said his
companion was on the phone with the
police to which I said they don't care
maybe they'll show up in a few hours
they'll likely make you go to the
station but this happens thousands of
times per week
so now I need to include a pre-visit
security brief to people traveling to
San Francisco this is a big reason I'm
hesitant to open an office in the City
versus keeping a remote team and
occasionally meeting up at a location to
whiteboard and my teammates will be
scarred forever being robbed hits you at
your core especially when it's thousands
of dollars lost there is no downtown
recovery without an aggressive push for
safety
that's what you tweet it now
scarred for life
maybe a slight overstatement or maybe
not because for those who live in safe
areas where people act like human beings
and treat each other decently and you
can leave a backpack in your car without
worrying about it being stolen where in
fact I've lived in places like this you
could leave a backpack in your car with
your car unlocked and still running
without anything being stolen like you
could run into the gas station with your
car running and the windows rolled down
and key in the ignition and nothing will
happen
so if you live in a place like that the
first real encounter with the culture in
an urban area can be quite jarring
so property crime can leave a scar in
this sense it will certainly leave you
you know more cynical than you were
before it Alters your outlook on
Humanity to whatever slight or not so
slight degree and I think this can be
especially difficult of an adjustment
for a liberal you know someone who
always assume that the the hand ringing
over crime in the city was driven by
racism only to experience the crime
himself and discover firsthand that not
only is the problem real but that it's
reasonable and Justified to be angry
about it
property crime is is extremely
unpleasant for anyone and I know this
from experience but I think this sort of
person uh is most scarred by it the sort
of person who shouts hey big it's stop
assuming that just because you're in the
city you're automatically going to be
the victim of crime
and then turns around and finds that
their Windows have been smashed
now I have no idea if the people in this
case are liberal or not but if they were
then it was a rude awakening
and whatever their ideological
persuasion they are justified in being
Furious about it you had something
stolen from you
but not everyone agrees on that last
point a guy named John hamasaki who's a
San Francisco resident
responded to this tweet thread with a
rather dismissive message he wrote quote
interesting would getting your car
window broken and some stuff stolen
leave you scarred forever is this what
you suburb is this what the suburbs do
to you
shelter you from basic City Life
Experiences so that when they happen
you're broke into the core I've had my
window broken two times when I was
living paycheck to paycheck it sucked
financially but it had zero impact on my
sense of Public Safety I can't even
imagine the world one must live in where
this would be the most traumatizing
incident in their life
again not to say it doesn't suck but
maybe City Life just isn't for you it's
not the suburbs there is crime I'm
grateful most of it is property crime
instead of violent crime but I've always
felt safe in San Francisco even after
being on the wrong side of violent crime
note one thing to begin with here he
scoffs at the notion that um being the
victim of actual crime might be scarring
for some people
yet I can guarantee that if this was a
tweet Thread about someone's traumatic
experience with being you know
misgendered
he would not be nearly so dismissive
these people will only give the hey
that's life deal with it treatment to
Crime Victims
right those The Crime Victims are the
only ones who get this kind of tough
love
they would never say it to those who are
victimized by words or by pronouns they
don't like
and note another thing too perhaps more
important than uh than that
which is that this man
who calls burglary a basic life
experience is a lawyer and not only is
he a lawyer but he is running for
district attorney of San Francisco
and given his exceedingly permissive
even accepting attitude towards crime
I'd say his chances of winning the job
are extremely high if history is any
indication at least
because as we've learned the most
important qualification for a D.A in the
city like a city like San Francisco is a
commitment to doing absolutely nothing
about crime and in that way hamasaki is
well suited for the job I suppose
and he's also not alone in this attitude
of course in fact this story May remind
you of a similar exchange involving a
former actor turned full-time pothead
Seth Rogen last year YouTuber Casey
neistat tweeted his experience with
crime but this was in Los Angeles he
said so our cars got robbed this morning
because Los Angeles is a crime-riddled
third world of a city but tremendous
appreciation and gratitude to the
hard-working officers at the LAPD who
not only arrested the mother effort but
they also got all of our stolen goods
back
Seth Rogen responded to that dude I've
lived here for over 20 years you're nuts
haha it's lovely here
don't leave anything valuable in it it's
called living in a big city
you continue later quote you could be
mad but I guess I don't personally view
my car as an extension of myself and
I've never really felt violated any of
the 15 or so times my car was broken
into
once a guy accidentally left a cool
knife in my car so if it keeps happening
you might get a little treat
so you notice a theme here
um
being a victim of crime
is simply
part of living life in the city
you know just as life in the country
means fresh air lots of space trees
nature
friendly people who would rather help
you than rob you
life in the city means stepping over
hypodermic needles smelling the stench
of human feces and urine and weed
everywhere having to factor a car window
replacements into your monthly budget
it seems that even The Advocates of City
Life agree on this point and will say so
like even they will if you associate
living in the city with crime and all
this kind of stuff apparently even the
people who live in the city who Advocate
living in the city will say yeah that's
what that's what city life is all about
15 times he's had his car broken into
how many times I've had my car broken
into at the age of 36 zero times
but I've also never lived directly in
the city
and most of the time I've lived far
outside the city
but the only difference is that they
think that the city dwellers or or even
people are just visiting should be okay
with all this so they'll agree that all
this stuff comes with living in the city
but they think that we should just be
okay with it
it's a worthwhile trade-off they say
though it's not clear what exactly you
get in exchange
you know because the trade-off is means
you get something in exchange so what
are you getting what do you get in
exchange for the filth and the crime
where's the upside crowds high prices
traffic
I'm seeing lots of cost in this cost
benefit analysis I don't really see the
benefit though
hamasaki would say that um
you know perhaps this means that City
life isn't for me and on that score at
least I completely agree
see we see here why the crime problem
exists in the first place
it exists because the people in charge
don't see the crime problem as a problem
it's actually very simple it's not even
that they're too incompetent to do
anything about it though they are also
incompetent of course but more to the
point even if they had the competence to
address the issue
they don't want to they don't care
enough they have no empathy for the
victims for the prey because they've
reserved all of their pity for the
Predators
is what you have to understand if you
decide to move to a big city you will be
moving into a place that is run by
people who truly do not care if you are
robbed raped or killed they don't care
in fact they don't think you have any
right to expect anything less
you have no right to even park your car
and expect that your windows will remain
intact
they don't see the safety of your person
or your property as a priority nor do
they see the violation of your personal
property as a problem
and of course you know a D.A who doesn't
see crime as a problem is a bit like an
oncologist who doesn't see cancer as a
problem in fact it's like an oncologist
who sympathizes more with the cancer
than with the patient
and these are the sorts of people we've
put in charge of fighting crime in our
cities people Afflicted with a cancer of
their own really a cancer of the Mind
called leftism
and that is why all of these people but
especially today John hamasaki are today
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to the members block if you're
not a member yet you can become a member
and use code wall should check out for
two months free on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]